so movement and motility is almost
synonymous with life when you peer
inside the inner life of a cell with a
microscope you can see that it's
churning with moving objects many of
these moving objects are small cargo
containers called membrane organelles or
vesicles these are essentially the
delivery trucks of the cell at the time
we were doing this experiment in 1984 we
really didn't have answers to those
fundamental questions of how that
motility occurs so our goal was to
figure it out
so we figured if we were going to
understand motility we should look at it
in a system which has the highest
concentration of all of these motility
components these moving organelles the
motor proteins and that's why we picked
the axon the axon is effectively a
dedicated Highway to molecular transport
a nerve cell unlike a liver cell or many
other cells is extraordinarily long one
part of the cell may be in your spinal
cord but the other end of that same cell
may be at the tip of your toe and in
between that cell body and your spinal
cord in your toe is a very very long
tube that's called the axon that
connects these very distal parts of the
same cell and this is essentially like
shipping things between one part of the
country and the other of all the axons
that you can possibly choose which one
would you choose
well we decided to work on the squid
giant axon it is a much larger axon than
an axon that you would find in a mammal
for example or a human
we made the guess that this would be a
good hunting ground to try to find which
are the motor machineries that are
causing this form of axonal transport
you